go from Hanukkah to a train ride of
sorts Mr tannenberg oh yeah The Polar
Express we were talking about this last
week so this was up at the Cimarron Rose
Community Center up on the North End of
town it was so much fun
[Music]
from the Las Vegas Academy High School
choir serenade before the start of the
show to getting everyone all aboard the
train we were ready
now meeting the dance team from
Centennial High School before the show I
could tell they'd be bringing the energy
to conferring with my fellow conductors
oh yeah we were off to the North Pole
the elves danced
kids and families danced and sang
and then
the big man showed up
we all snapped pictures with him before
heading home
so those are actually the sports courts
Outdoors at the cimron Rose community
center off of Ann Road and the 95 and
they built this thing that sort of looks
like the Polar Express but it was just a
bunch of tables with a lot of families
from the neighborhood hanging out there
and a big shout out to Aaron Clark and
the folks at the community center for
inviting me and the tip of the
conductors cap it's a small But Mighty
Little Engine That Could staff a lot of
energy enthusiasm and camaraderie did it
for three nights and it's just to serve
that neighborhood I love that right
there's so many things happening around
the valley in like the little
neighborhood events just like yeah